les yvelinois ont le vent en poupe après
les élections de yale brawn pie v au
perchoir et d'horreur berger à la
présidence du groupe renaissance à
l'assemblée nationale c'est au tour de
jean noël barrot 39 ans d'être dans la
lumière le député des yvelines est nommé
ministre délégué à la transition
numérique et aux télécommunications dans
le deuxième gouvernement d'elisabeth
bornes honoré de la confiance qui m'est
faite par emmanuel macron elisabeth
bornes très heureux devrait désormais
auprès de bruno le maire en tant que
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et les télécommunications au
travail devenu parlementaire pour la
première fois en 2010 est le député de
la 2e circonscription des yvelines a été
réélu au second tour des dernières
législatives avec 64,27 % des suffrages
il a occupé pendant cinq ans le poste de
vice président de la commission des
finances à l'assemblée nationale proche
de françois bayrou jean noël barrot
également secrétaire général du modem
représentait le candidat idéal le
mouvement démocrate est un allié de la
majorité présidentielle des manuels
macron évidemment c'est satisfaisant je
le disais on lui souhaite bien du
courage et en tout cas on lui souhaite
et bien beaucoup de réussite dans ce
nouveau dispositif gouvernemental auprès
de la première ministre et isabelle
borne et jean-noël barrot sera
accompagné de trois collègues du
mouvement démocrate ce qui portera à 4
le nombre de ministres modem dans ce
gouvernement mais voilà c'est en plus
d'être un homme politique qui fait de la
politique autrement qui a toujours
oeuvré à l'assemblée nationale avec avec
beaucoup d'engagement c'est quelqu'un
qui est porteur de valeurs qui nous sont
chères et diplômé de hec et de sciences
po paris il est issu d'une lignée
d'hommes politiques son père jacques
barrot était membre du conseil
constitutionnel et a été plusieurs fois
ministre du commerce de la santé et du
travail son grand père noël barrot lui
faisait partie de la résistance durant
la seconde guerre mondiale et était
également un député centriste sous
charles de gaulle jean noël barrot
exercera ses nouvelles fonctions auprès
du ministre de l'économie bruno le maire